♪ (GENTLE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Hi, I'm Susie Essman
from Curb Your Enthusiasm.
If you're like me,
there's nothing better than
kicking back and relaxing
after a long day.
But sometimes,
it's hard to turn off the world
and de-stress
without the right soundtrack
to get you there.
Until now.
Presenting...
The Sweet Sounds of Susie.
There's no music,
there's no tempo.
It's just me, Susie,
reciting my most soothing lines
from Curb,
with absolutely no filler.
Featuring such classics as...
(READS YELLOW PROMPTS)
...and more.
The collection has it all.
So why wait?
Listen to
The Sweet Sounds of Susie today
and sleep like a baby tonight.
You can thank me later.
Listen to
The Sweet Sounds of Susie
presented by
Curb Your Enthusiasm,
available on Spotify.